Marvel fans are about to get a whole lot more
Thor — and we mean that literally.
At Marvel's 2019 Comic-Con panel, it was announced
that Natalie Portman would reprise her role
as Jane Foster for Thor: Love and Thunder,
which will see her become the new Thor.
Here's how Portman reacted to the news.
Visibly giddy over the announcement, Portman
took to the Hall H stage to share her feelings
about being the next Thor.
She walked across the panel, backed by the
cheers of hundreds of Hall H attendees, to
accept a prop Mjolnir from director Taika
Waititi.
Clearly, Portman is excited about her character
Jane taking over as the first female Thor
and the second iteration of the god of thunder
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
But she knows what it takes to be a superhero,
and the actress is fully prepared for the
same workouts that transformed Tom Holland
and Brie Larson for their own superheroic
roles.
After Marvel's SDCC presentation, Portman
shared two photos of herself on stage with
Mjolnir, writing that she wants everyone to
remember what she looked like during the panel
so they can compare it to her physique in
Thor: Love and Thunder.
Thor: Love and Thunder takes inspiration from
The Mighty Thor comic series by Jason Aaron
and Russell Dauterman, which turns astrophysicist
Jane Foster into a new iteration of the God
of Thunder.
At the start of the series, Jane is battling
breast cancer when she learns she can carry
the mystical hammer and take over for Thor
after he loses his ability to wield it.
In the series, Jane's use of Mjolnir and transformations
into Thor actually exacerbates the side effects
of her cancer.
It's unclear how much of this arc Thor: Love
and Thunder will adapt, but if they stay true
to the comic storyline, it might be a pretty
emotional ride.
It's also bound to be an action-packed one,
as the female Thor possesses all the same
abilities the Odinson does as well as something
extra.
In The Mighty Thor, Jane has an extra-keen
dominion over Mjolnir, and can alter its velocity
and trajectory after she's already thrown
it; she can also round up enemies with Mjolnir
by sending it swirling around their bodies.
The Mighty Thor mastermind Aaron couldn't
be happier that the female Thor is coming
to the MCU, and is eager to see how Portman
approaches this new side of Jane Foster.
He tweeted:
"Well, wow."
"Consider me thunderously excited.
The Jane Foster Thor storyline I did with
@rdauterman, (Eisner winner!)
@COLORnMATT & so many more talented artists
is one of my proudest moments in comics.
I can't wait to see TaikaWaititi & Natalie
Portman bring the Goddess of Thunder to life."
Whatever your thoughts on Portman becoming
the new Thor are, there's no denying that
this is huge news for the actress.
The last fans saw of her in the MCU was in
Thor: The Dark World, after which she and
Thor broke up off-screen.
Portman herself had also seemingly parted
ways with the Marvel movie world after the
Thor sequel, telling The Wall Street Journal
in 2016:
"As far as I know, I'm done."
Of course, we know now that Portman isn't
through with the MCU — and she may not be
done with Thor, either.
Marvel hasn't said one way or another whether
Jane and Thor will give their relationship
another shot in Love and Thunder, but we're
betting it's possible.
“Sorry to hear Jane dumped you.”
“She didn’t dump me, you know.
I dumped her.
It was a mutual dumping.”
After all, the two are both worthy of wielding
Mjolnir in the eyes of the Asgardian gods.
It seems as if their romance was written in
the stars.
See Natalie Portman's Jane Foster become the
new Thor when Thor: Love and Thunder hits
theaters on November 5th, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU's
Phase 4 are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.